if you grew up with the 1990 miniseries
adaptation of Stephen King's it brace
yourself the 2017 film version pulls all
the gore and insanity straight from the
pages of Stephen King's blood-soaked
1986 novel the movie follows the seven
kids in the losers Club as they try to
Ford an evil clown shaped nightmare in
the small town of Derry Maine let's take
a trip down into the sewers to look at
all the Easter eggs you missed in it
warning some spoilers ahead also clowns
lots of clowns the penny wise doll
during the losers club's first visit to
the rundown house a twenty nine niebolt
street bill Eddie and Ritchie get
separated and Ritchie finds himself
locked in literally the worst place ever
a room full of clown dolls but look
closely because they aren't just any
terrifying clown dolls just to the left
of the spot where Pennywise pops out
stands a figure who may look familiar
Pennywise from the 1990 miniseries as
portrayed by Tim Curry werewolf hands in
both the book and the miniseries
Ritchie's main fear as werewolves a fear
he gets after watching I was a teenage
werewolf at the local theater so
naturally that's the shape the evil fear
sucking clown usually takes when it
appears for him and while there aren't
any werewolves howling at the dairy moon
in the 2017 it audiences do get a quick
glimpse of that Lupo phobia during the
encounter at Twentynine niebolt street
while the monster advances on Eddie Bill
Ritchie and Beverly you can see werewolf
claws start to rip through its clown
gloves it's just a quick moment but it
shows the filmmakers were thinking of
the fans even as they were deciding to
pretty much forget about see gene a big
goofy werewolf
tracker brothers from Eddie's Airwolf
t-shirt to the bully belch Huggins
anthrax tea the kids outfits are all
about the sweet nostalgia of childhood
in the late 80s which is why one shirt
in particular stands out when Eddie
Ritchie Stan and Bill go looking for
Georgie in the drainage pipe in the
Barrens early in the movie Bill's
wearing a green shirt with a nondescript
round logo in the center if you look
closely though you can see that the logo
says tracker brothers in the novel
tracker brothers as a company in Derry
and their Factory is where grown-up
Eddie first meets Pennywise when he gets
back to Derry Christine bill isn't the
only it character who boasts a cot me
Easter egg in this movie one of Eddie's
shirts also harkens back to Kings other
works with a design of an angry car with
what appears to be a chrome V on the
front if that sounds familiar you've
probably read Christine Kings 1983 novel
about a killer car or seen the film
adaptation interestingly enough
Christine also makes an appearance in
the it novel or at least a red-and-white
1958 Plymouth Fury being driven by a
corpse shows up what else could that be
friezes department store was every
Easter Egg in this movie printed on a
t-shirt we also see Ritchie wearing a
shirt proudly advertising freezes you've
probably never shopped there and for
good reason
freezes was a department store in Bangor
Maine that operated from 1892 to 1985 so
why would Ritchie wear a shirt from a
defunct store that operated in a
completely different town well Bangor
just happens to be Stephen King's
longtime home a nod to the creator of it
yeah we can definitely believe that
silver the movie doesn't pay any special
attention to the kid spikes and for the
most part the audience won't either but
fans of the story may have noticed one
bike in particular that plays a big part
in the original novel Bills silver
Schwinn which happens to have the word
silver printed on the frame in the book
that bike actually saves two lives once
in the 50s when bill uses it to save
Eddie from an asthma attack and once in
the 80s when grown-up bill drives down
the middle of traffic on a busy street
to jolt his wife out of catalepsy
although none of that happened in the
movie the small detail of putting a name
on Bill's beloved bike probably wasn't
lost on fans the Bradley Gang the
filmmakers stuck a ton of tiny details
in the background of it
the one of the best was the mural of the
Bradley gang shootout you get a few
glimpses of it on the brick wall when
mike hamlin hallucinates the burning
hands reaching through the door in the
book the Bradley gang was a group of
outlaws who were killed by the dairy
townsfolk in 1929 which was the last
time penny wise was awake before the
losers Club confronts him it's an
excellent nod to the source material for
anyone paying attention although most
people were probably pretty distracted
by the charred hams clawing at the
doorframe deadlights in the novel penny
wise is an ancient cosmic beam that came
into our universe because humans have
good imaginations and all that
imagination and fear makes its food
taste good
he's not really a clown but clowns are
scary and good at learning children so
he kind of sticks with it what he really
is is something called dead lights which
are energy thingies that usually look
like undulating orange orbs this guy saw
them any went crazy the movie doesn't
mention the dead lights at all because
well never said that name out loud
before it sounds stupid now that I see
just you calm whatever you want but
there is one quick glimpse of the dead
lights after Pennywise kidnaps beverly
and takes her to his sewer lair beverly
looks down his throat to see three
orange lights swirling around each other
a moment later she's comatose and
floating in the air
it's a giant WTF moment for anyone new
to the story but diehard fans gave a
silent cheer whether or not the cosmic
side of penny wise has explored more
deeply in part two is uncertain as of
this video but the quick cameo of penny
wise is true form in the first part
certainly makes for satisfying Easter
egg thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too
[Music]